je n'ai pas ce député je n'ai jamais eu
de compte à l'étranger dont quoi que
vous vous tombé de l'armoire
jonquerettes vous dire que je n'étais
pas le garde du corps d'emmanuel m
[Musique]
et
salut c'est parti pour l'analyse on vous
avait dit dans la vidéo du mois de
décembre qui en aurait une par mois et
du coup il y en a car loïc une par mois
une parme et cette vidéo va être
beaucoup avec toi parce que je suis
fatigué donc j'ai un peu les conneries
donc j'ai envie de parler avec toi mais
aussi avec eux je vous rappelle que
quand je suis dans cette énergie
ça peut être fatigant pour vous parce
qu'apparemment je droit que d'être
sérieux parfois donc ne vous étonnez pas
aujourd'hui ça j'ai un peu la connerie
et ça tombe bien que j'aie la connerie
parce qu'aujourd'hui on va faire une
analyse d'un nouveau genre c'est à dire
que pour une fois ce sera passé à chaque
fois loin de là c'est juste une fois on
va faire de l'analyse a posteriori de
personnes qui ont déjà été jugés c'est à
dire des personnes telles que balkany
benalla cahuzac l'hilton kerviel lance
amstrong
c'est à dire quoi quand même bien rigolé
a beau programme en perspective le il
dit moi une saynète complètement délire
qui me passe par la tête
chien oui oui je veux voir ça maintenant
dans le montage tout tient le facteur
avec une baguette y attend j'ai une
baguette double vague est donnée ou êtes
sûr c'est une boulangerie c'est bizarre
aux règles des habits qui tourne
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
merci à eux et c'était bien fait en plus
ok donc on va analyser ça un parent ça
va être du verbal et du non verbal ça va
être les deux mélangés parce que tenir
le monde on connaît des données et que
ses déclarations publiques dans le non
verbal je sais pas sur quelle énormément
de choses mais comme vous le savez pour
le non verbal il faut comprendre la
baseline vers un tout l'ensemble
l'environnement et/ou et le verbal est
important aussi dans le domaine là je
pense qu'on va commencer par ceux
chauffés par balkany analyse loïc tanfin
gpat analyse et toi tu veux commencer
par balkany ou pas moi j'étais assez
chaud pour commencer balkany mis en
examen j'ai simplement expliqué au
magistrat que je l'avais strictement
rien à voir avec ceux qui me
reprochaient quand on a rien à se
reprocher on se sent bien
maintenant qu'ils fassent leur enquête
on a on a eu le mépris ou la justice''
le mépris vous allez je vous ai déjà
parlé de cette micro expressions la
séquence était la seule d'ailleurs micro
expressions qui est asymétrique
on a le mépris qui est ici donc je pense
que là ils méprisent la personne dont il
parle c'est est la personne qui font
l'enquète sur lui le seul problème c'est
que je n'ai pas de société je n'ai pas
de compte j'ai pas de comptes à saint
agathon j'ai pas de société voilà les
choses sont très simples
alors là effectivement on voit rien de
particulier parce qu'il disait la vérité
à ce moment là en fait c'est pas un
idiot un balkany 1 il a quand même
préparé un petit peu le terrain et donc
tout ce qu'il dit là et a priori bret il
n'y a pas de société à lui il n'a pas de
comptes à lui donc ok tout ça a été vrai
attention j'ai pas fait le disclaimer de
d'habitude que les teams mais il faut le
faire tout de suite
allons-y bonjour je m'appelle famille en
lit car je suis auto proclamé mentalist
et à ce titre ge utilise des techniques
que je pioche un petit peu dans tous les
domaines ce que je dis est pas forcément
la vérité n'est pas forcément une
science exacte c'est que mon avis à moi
en plus des fois que j'utilise des trucs
qui viennent du domaine de pseudo
science un petit peu comme les semis au
logis même si je pioche pas trop dedans
donc quand même on fait gaffe à ce que
je dis je me suis pas autoproclamé comme
le plus grand spécialiste de la planète
merci merci à toi ça fait 30 ans que
j'ai même raison
de quoi pour vous vous tombé de
l'armoire alors monsieur j'ai fini de
vous parler maintenant vous pouvez
sortir et quitter ma permanence
ok là sur une colère on peut pas
analyser grand chose par contre on voit
bien qu'ils se trompent d'expression
c'est à dire quand il dit loïc tu es
tombé de l'armoire ou quoi ce que tu
connais cette expression non et bien
balkany l'a inventé en fait cette montre
juste que l'agacement et la confusion
est telle que tu ne sais plus quoi dire
en fait tu sais plus trop tenir à
l'époque on était en train de les
interroger
concernant la ville à pamplemousses et
apparemment c'est ça le gonfle
particulièrement qu'on lui en parle
simplement vous dire comme nous l'avons
toujours dit et comme cela s est
confirmé publiquement et officiellement
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un centime
d'argent public
c'est uniquement notre patrimoine
familial et il n'y a pas de corruption
merci c'est super intéressant c'est du
non verbal parce que on va s'intéresser
aux intonations d'isabelle balkany et
non pas à ce qu'elle dit mais après on
va les rapprocher
je leur mets juste un tout petit peu
avant quand elle dit qu'elle n'a jamais
touché un centime de l'argent public et
qu'il n'y a jamais eu de corruption
écoutez la différence de nuances entre
les deux il n'y a pas un centime
d'argent public
uniquement notre patrimoine familial et
il n'y a pas de corruption
vous voyez l'émotionnel qu'elle met sur
le fait qu'ils aient pas de corruption
en détachant elle ne met pas de
superlatifs à mais pas de choses comme
ça les justes vénère là dessus alors que
l'autre allait aussi stoïque que
d'habitude par rapport à ça par rapport
aux deux jugements qu'ils ont eue les
jugements ont démontré plusieurs choses
déjà que la villa bon plume ou c'était à
eux que le riz à dte qui a eu du
blanchiment de l'argent de la fraude
fiscale donc ça c'est de l'argent public
par contre ils ont été complètement
relaxé en ce qui concerne les
accusations de corruption ils ont a
priori corrompu personnes alors qu'on
pensait qu'il y avait un truc dans le
btp etc
et c'est intéressant là a posteriori de
regarder la différence de ton calme et à
chaque fois elle quand elle parle allez
plutôt calme mais stoïque
il ya juste sur sa où elle monte en fait
dans les tours mais ne met pas de
superlatifs partout qui est signe du
mensonge
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a fait balkany
patrick balkany la première vidéo qu'on
a regardé simplement évidemment
forcément caisse en france loïc quel est
ton analyse l'analyse de mon analyse
s'il te plaît parce que à tomber bien
alors on peut remarquer chez fabien
comme vous venez de voir à l'instant il
parle beaucoup avec les mains
ce qui est une emphase théorique sur la
3eme jonction connaît voilà je le peux
me permettre d'analyser ton analyse de
mon analyse loïc était stressé on
continue est ce que tu crois qu'un jour
on fera un duo loïc acquis c'est aux
affaires macfag beloki tôt olala là
s'est moqué je te laisse analyser le oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe il est en train
de dire je n'ai pas je n'ai jamais eu
regarde bien tu n'as pas le sens tu as
que le visage qu'est ce que tu peux m'en
dire loïc et oui je n'ai pas monsieur le
député je n'ai jamais eu en fait je n'ai
pas monsieur le député je n'ai jamais eu
et je n'aurais jamais cru quand à
l'autre et ça c'est un signe de
faiblesse un il s'appuyant il déglutit
beaucoup bouche sèche et puis bouge pas
le regard on a toujours le regard fixe
c'est ça c'est toujours terrible je
voulais déjà dit en général quand on
ment on a le regard fixe on a le regard
qui bouge pas beaucoup donc à illzach
quand même qui a été condamné parce que
ils avaient des comptes en suisse où il
m'était du cash qui récupéré et qu'il
envoyait après 2,9
société où charles je crois qu'il était
basé à hong kong il me semble alors
qu'il était ministre
et quelle était sa mission principale
lutter contre la fraude fiscale
je lui quand même alors vraiment foutage
de gueule puissance mille selon
mediapart dit la connaître mais le grand
public ne la connaîtra jamais jérôme
cahuzac
j'espère que le grand public notamment
après cette émission hu quand il dit est
ce que le grand public connaîtra un jour
la vérité
on a juste un tout petit changement que
tu un spa une image de grande qualité
mais il ya une micro expressions qui
passe j'arrive pas à voir laquelle away
regardez vous avez vu on n'est pas bien
sûr le potentiel publique qui pourrait
connaître la vérité je sais pas si c'est
de la peur il écarquille pas assez les
yeux pour avoir la peur mais on est
quand même sur un stress et sur un
contrôle jérôme ça sent pas bon en vrai
là il n'y a pas grand chose de plus à
dire mon cher loïc mais c'est juste fou
de se dire que cet élu qui était détaché
à la mission prioritaire de la fraude
fiscale avait monté un système complexe
et il a nié il a nié partout dans toutes
les radios devant l'assemblée nationale
qu'est-ce qui se passe psychologiquement
pour des personnages tels que balkany ou
kayak pour affirmer publiquement en
permanence et c'est que que non non non
jusqu au cas où quoi tu vois tu me diras
largeur n'existe pas en france
malheureusement mais pas comme aux états
unis mais c'est quand même fou en même
temps tu me diras que tu sais quoi
qu'elle isaac
c'est ce qu'il a eue cahuzac même pour
avoir fait ça il a eu quatre ans dont
deux avec sursis
donc les deux avec sursis évidemment il
n'ya pas les faire les deux qui reste
quand tu as une condamnation dans ce
cadre-là de deux ans tu peux tout de
suite demandé un aménagement de la peine
c'est à dire rester à domicile où il ya
des cautions des machins des trucs comme
ça et c'est ce qu'il a obtenu donc
nombre de jours en prison vous laisse à
présent des cols blancs 0 il n'y a pas
fait de tôles je suis au regret de vous
dire je n'étais pas le garde du corps
d'emmanuel macro je n'ai jamais été le
garde du corps d'emmanuel macron alors
là pour le coup on a plutôt un pléonasme
satisfaisant puisqu'ils dit je n'ai pas
été le garde du corps d'emmanuel macron
et on sent que ce geste là n'est pas
contrôlé deux personnes qui étaient en
charge la protection qui étaient dans la
voiture avec emmanuel macron qui
l'accompagné partout même là où je
n'allais pas le soir
et rendez vous dans l'un des matchs et
des médias etc je n'étais pas avec lui
moi j'avais une tâche d'organisation
générale de sécurité générale mais sur
des meetings
j'étais proche de lui physiquement c'est
assez incroyable hein on n'a pas
beaucoup plus de vidéos la de benanou a
analysé ce qu'on est obligé de
travailler avec des vidéos qu'on a le
droit de diffuser etc il ya quelque
chose qui est fou en fait c'est à dire
qu'il ya un sang froid une maîtrise qui
est elle
je connais pas sa formation mais je
crois qu'il a une formation solide soit
militaires soient d'anciens gardes du
corps ou de choses comme ça en tout cas
il un sang-froid qui est terrible sa
manière de s'exprimer extrêmement propre
extrêmement réfléchi mais du coup on n'a
ni la colère ou le désespoir de quand il
accuse à tort ni l'agacement de quand tu
viens de te faire choper que un peu
comme balkanique ans et s'est énervé
qu'il a pris la caméra
en fait c'est terrible quand même de se
dire ok on voit pas grand chose dans un
sens ou dans l'autre si ce n'est qu'a
priori effectivement je pense pas qu'il
était le garde du corps de macron mais
il a été autre chose quelque chose qui
n'est pas clair et quelque chose qui
n'est pas clair d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que on a de
moins en moins d'infos sur lui sur
larmes sur le coffre-fort cap a été
retrouvé sur qui la lui a donnée les
papiers ou pas il ya un truc derrière ce
dos de bena là c'est pas de la
diffamation ce que je fais mais c'est
vraiment c'est pas clair si c'était
clair ils n'auraient pas ce discours là
par exemple à ce moment là il aurait pas
besoin de d'étayer sa de dire non j'ai
pas été le garde du corps de de monsieur
macro et j'ai pas fait si j'ai pas fait
c'est un point tu vois et je vous le
prouve par ça ça c'est n'est jamais
clair par contre c'est fait avec
beaucoup de retenue
buyster avait bien été marrant ça
c'était c'était le seul moment sincère
donc il accusé de dopage
à ce moment là c'est un cycliste très
réputé est juste là qu'en étant la tête
il fait on dit ce qu'on a dit on fait ce
qu'on a fait on n'a rien à cacher
derrière ces deux là juste après qu'il
ait dit ça on sent qu en fait il ya une
toute petite décroche juste là hop là on
a la honte loïc on à la première compte
j'avais jamais vu ça à l'époque visage
baissé ici en pince on regarde vers le
bas on penche un petit peu on a tous les
signaux de la honte et c'est la première
fois qu'ils expriment sur le fait est ce
que vous êtes dopé nuit dit non
démarrant de dire non et d'avoir honte
quand même là faut que je vous dise on a
regardé on va pas tout vous faire voir
là c'est quand il s'est fait gauler
comme tous ceux qui sont ou vraiment
gaulle est dédié rake de 6 dopé en fait
et elle va lui poser une question
essentielle qui est est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'avoir triché
regardez je veux même enlevé je ne dis
plus rien olala cette série ils sont
terribles c'est un défi fou tout ça il
faut on peut croire tout personne quoi
je me dis est-ce que juste on
s'arrêterait pas là pour aujourd'hui on
voit si vous appréciez aussi juste petit
retour pas très approfondie on en passe
là en masse on regarde les choses et on
sait déjà le résultat est juste en haut
on peut constater ça et du coup dans ce
cas là on fait un épisode de où je
mettrais eux et d'autres que vous pouvez
me proposait déjà dans les commentaires
ou alors on ne fait exclusivement que
les analyses tels qu'on les fait
aujourd'hui sur des a priori non pas des
a posteriori je sais pas pourquoi je me
lève pour pas partir d'accords au 1
ok abonnez vous à cette chaîne youtube
activer la cloche parce qu'on ne sait
jamais quand les vidéos sortiez plus de
dates ou d'heures ou de jours de sortie
ça peut sortir mercredi soir à 5 heures
du matin on ne sait pas mais du coup
cinq heures du matin et soir
waouh merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la
vidéo je vous embrasse regarder
l'épisode de deux matchs à gries est
sorti il ya pas longtemps
et regardez également la vidéo où je
vous parle de la sortie de mon magazine
si vous n'êtes pas abonné
vous pouvez encore le faire et vous avez
ça ici et ici autour de moi moi je vous
le dit temps en temps quand je suis
fatigué je suis je me lâche
les belges douzaine à très bientôt le
show biz ou